ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBERS AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER* BATH.
BONTA.
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DAILY.
DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE
OF US ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TEEN VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS.
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE FRONT OF
THE CHAMBER PLEASE.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS PAST MONDAY.
BEING PRESIDENT'S DAY IN ON
TUESDAY HAVING OR DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE.
LET US TAKE A MOMENT TO REFLECT
ON WHAT IT IS TO BE AN AMERICAN.
ONE MONTH IN FOUR DAYS AGO
BOUNCES ATTENDED THE MEMORIAL
SERVICE FOR OFFICER NAVVY CORONA.
HOW QUICKLY ONE MONTH HAS GONE
BY?
BUT WE WHO HAVE KNOWN REAL LOS.
WE KNOW THE HER FAMILY LOOKS AT
THE CALENDAR.
AND ALTHOUGH THEY SEE THAT THE
DAYS ARE PASSING. FOR THEM.
TIME HAS JUST STOPPED. FOR THAT
IS HOW IT FEELS WHEN WE LOSE
SOMEONE WE LOVE.
MY HEART STILL ACHES.
KNOWING THE UNACCEPTABLE LOSS
HER PARENTS CANNOT HELP BUT FEEL.
BUT TODAY I'D LIKE US TO
REMEMBER AND REFLECT ON WORDS.
THAT HER FATHER A RETIRED DEPUTY
SHERIFF.
SPOKE LAST MONTH TO HER SERVICE.
HE SAID.
AS THE DAUGHTER OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS.
SHE KNEW THAT YOU CAN BE A FOR
BLOODED AMERICAN WHILE RETAINING
YOUR CULTURAL ROOTS.
IF ALL OF AMERICA COULD NO HIS
PAIN.
AND FEEL THE WEIGHT OF THE WORDS
HE SHARED.
IT WOULD DEEPEN OUR ADMIRATION
FOR THIS DREAM.
THAT DIVERSITY HAS GIVEN TO
DEMOCRACY.
LIKE OFFICER NOW THE CORONA.
THAT BEING AN AMERICAN ALSO
STAND FOR THE FREEDOM. TO PURSUE
A DREAM TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE.
LET US AGAIN OPEN OUR SESSION
WITH LOVING GRATITUDE. FOR ALL
WHO DEDICATE THEMSELVES TO
MAKING OUR WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER SOON WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND ASHA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
READY AGAIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG [inaudible]
AND ISRAEL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
WILL MOVE TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
FEBRUARY SEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
DECENTLY MINUTE NINE AM ON WILL
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHEAP
CLICKY DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
REAL QUICK HOW MISTER BONTA
MOVES AND MISTER KILEY SECONDS
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
AS INDICATIONS IN PETITIONS
THERE ARE.
NINE INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ARE ABSENCES TODAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CALDERON WORK AND MELENDEZ.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND.
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KALRA
PETRIE-NORRIS TANG AND OBERNOLTE
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATCHY NORRIS'S
GUEST WILL BE SEATED AT HER DESK
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. FOR THE REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GRAY FRAZIER AND KILEY. TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE GUESTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY.
CAN WE PLEASE GIVE OUR ATTENTION
TO OUR GAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY S..
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE WELCOME UP IN
THE GALLERY THE CSU [inaudible]
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY COMMIT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE OR I TAX.
COMPRISED OF THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICERS OF ALL
TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES AS
WELL AS MEMBERS FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
AS WE KNOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY PLAYS A CRUCIAL ROLE
IN ENSURING CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION.
THESE UNIVERSITIES ALL ART MUCH
LIKE ANY OTHER INDUSTRY WORKING
HARD TO KEEP THE CSU SYSTEM AS
TECHNICAL TECHNOLOGICALLY
ADVANCED AS POSSIBLE.
THE WORK OF THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS
CRUCIAL IN ADVANCING OUR
STUDENTS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE FEEL
LIKE SOON TO GO WHO IS FROM
DECEMBER TO DO YOU KNOW NOW WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM THIS MORNING TO
THE CAPITAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSN
WELCOME TEAR GAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION
[inaudible]
THE THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AS MY HONOR ON BEHALF OF THE
SPEAKER RENDON THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME A GAS
FROM CANADA --
OR WONDERFUL PARTNERS TO THE
NORTH AND AND SUCH IMPORTANT --
ALLIES IN TERMS OF SO MANY
DIFFERENT GOALS THAT WE HAVE AS
A STATE.
RESPECT WE AS A NATION --
FOR CANADA.
CANADA'S CAM TRAILER FOR FORTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN GOODS
ANNUALLY.
OVER ONE POINT TWO MILLION JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA DEPEND ON TRADE
AND INVESTMENT WITH CANADA.
AND EVERY YEAR OVER TWO MILLION
CANADIANS VISIT CALIFORNIA'S
SPEND MORE THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS WHILE IN THE
STATE.
CANADA IS THE WORLD'S SINGLE
LARGEST PURCHASER OF CALIFORNIA
WINES.
THE RESULT WAS THERE ON AVERAGE
CAñADA PURCHASE OVER PARTS OVER
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA WINE EVERY YEAR.
ANNUALLY ANNUALLY CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN FRUITS AND NUTS TO
CANADA.
AND OVER NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN VEGETABLES
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SIMILARLY TO CANADA AND THAT'S
WHY THIS FRIENDSHIP IS SO
IMPORTANT.
WHETHER IT'S CLEAN TAX --
HEALTH CARE CANNABIS POLICY OF
COURSE WE TALK ABOUT AGRICULTURE
AS WELL AS DEALING WITH THE
CRISIS OF GLOBAL WARMING.
CANADA IS AND HAS BEEN A PARTNER
AND THAT'S WHY SUCH A GREAT
HONOR ON BEHALF OF THE SPEAKER.
I TO INTRODUCE AND WELCOME OUR
CONSUL GENERAL FOR SAN FRANCISCO
FOR THE GREAT NATION OF CANADA
RUN US OUR CAR.
WHO WAS APPOINTED CONSUL GENERAL
OF CANADA IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AND HAWAII --
AS A MEMBER ACCOUNT IS NOW AFTER
ADVISORY CAN ALSO THE START AND
HE'S CO CHAIRMAN OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD OF THE MONTH SCHOOL OF
GLOBAL AFFAIRS.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO.
420-009-22000 THIRTEEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CANADA INDIA
BUSINESS COUNCIL --
AND IS A MEMBER OF THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL OF THE MALL WHAT CENTER
FOR POLICY INNOVATION CANADA.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE LITERARY
REVIEW OF CANADA AND A
DISTINGUISHED FELLOW AT THE MOST
WILL GLOBAL AFFAIRS AT
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THERE
IS A NEW CONSUL GENERAL FOR LOS
ANGELES COULD NOT BE WITH US
THIS MORNING AS I SHAKE WHO WAS.
APPOINTED CONSUL GENERAL CANADA
LOS ANGELES.
IN DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WALKING WELCOMING HIM.
ON TO THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOPEFULLY VERY VERY SOON AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO POINT OUT
THAT BOTH.
MR SARKARI MISTER SCHECK ABOUT
SOUTH ASIANS AS WELL SO THERE'S
A LOT OF CONNECTIONS THERE ARE
GOING ON HERE WITH CANADA.
AND TERMS REFLECTING DIVERSITY
THAT HAD NEVER BEEN REFLECT THE
BEFORE AND THESE TYPES OF VERY
IMPORTANT DIPLOMATIC POSITION.
AND WITH THAT --
MY COLLEAGUES TO MISTER ABOUT OF
HERE ON THE
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
OUR RESPECT OUR GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT
REALLY IS MY HONOR ON BEHALF OF
SPEAKER RENDON.
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER OBERNOLTE TO
PRESENT OUR NEW LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST MISTER GAVE THE TACK.
MISTER PROTECT IS THE SIX THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S IN THE
OFFICE HISTORY.
AND AS YOU KNOW IT'S A FAIRLY
HISTORIC POSITION THE OFFICE IS
WHAT.
THE CONGRESS BASE THEIR
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE
UNDER IN REALLY WE WERE IT WAS
VERY EXCITED TO BE PART OF THE
SEARCH COMMITTEE THAT MYSELF
MISTER OBERNOLTE SENATORS
MITCHELL AND NIELSEN WERE PART
OF HE WENT THROUGH A VERY
RIGOROUS PROCESS BUT WE IDENTIFY
SOMEONE WHO WE THOUGHT.
COULD REALLY LEAVE THE LA IN
THIS NEXT.
CHAPTER OF ITS HISTORY --
ONE OF THE MAJOR THINGS THAT WE
WERE HOPING TO FIND IS SOMEONE
WHO IS GOING TO BE.
WORKING MUCH CLOSER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY BE MUCH MORE
OF A PARTNER --
THE VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
ANALYTICAL BUT THE SAME TIME
THIS CALL AND POLICY ISSUES OF
THE DAY --
PRIOR TO JOINING THE LA I'LL
MISS BATAK WAS THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF THE STANDARD AND
POOR'S OFFICE IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH IS WHERE HE SPENT.
HIS ENTIRE CAREER TO THIS POINT.
VERY MUCH VERY EXCITED TO
WELCOME IS PROTECTED THERE --
TO SACRAMENTO AND AS OUR NEW LA
OUT WHEN I GOT TO TURN IT OVER.
TO MR OBERNOLTE FOR A FEW
COMMENTS AS WELL.
SO I'D LIKE TO JOIN MISTER TANK
IN WELCOMING MISTER PROTECT TO
THE OFFICE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST --
WE HAD A VERY LONG AND INVOLVED
SEARCH PROCESS FOR HIS
REPLACEMENT AND I AM PROUD TO
SAY THAT THE BICAMERAL IN
BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE THAT
SELECTED HIM MEDIAN ANIMUS
DECISION AND RECOMMENDING HIM TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WE ARE HIGHLY CONFIDENT THAT HE
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE THE
TRADITION OF EXCELLENCE IN THE
LA -- AND I
CALL THE ONLY --
THE UNSUNG HEROES OF THE
LEGISLATURE --
THEY DO THEIR JOB INCREDIBLY
EFFICIENCY EFFICIENTLY THEY HAVE
THE SAME NUMBER OF ANALYSTS NOW
AS THEY HAD IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AND THE SIZE
OF THE BUDGET IN THE PROGRAMS AT
THE OVERSEAS GROWN BY OVER 5000%
SO I'M HIGHLY CONFIDENT THAT MR
PROTECT.
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL IN THIS NEW
ROLE AND WOULD LIKE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE IN WELCOMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE HIM TO THE
LEGISLATURE
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible] TWENTY MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS A
RELATIVE TO INTRODUCE A GIRL TO
ENGINEERING DAY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THOUSAND OAKS I AM EXCITED TO
PRESENT ACR TWENTY ONE THAT
RECOGNIZES TODAY AS INTRODUCED A
GIRL TO ENGINEERING DAY.
WOMEN CONTINUE TO BE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN ENGINEERING FEELS
ABOUT 20% OF BACHELOR'S DEGREES
IN ENGINEERING ARE AWARDED TO
WOMEN AND WOMEN ACCOUNT FOR ONLY
13% OF ALL PRACTICING ENGINEERS
OFTEN EARNING LESS THAN THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS.
PEOPLE SAY THAT IT'S BECAUSE
GIRLS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN STEM
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
AS AN ENGINEER MYSELF AND A
FOUNDER OF D. I. Y. GIRLS A
NONPROFIT THAT GETS GIRLS
INTERESTED IN STEM.
I CAN TELL YOU THE GIRLS ARE
VERY INTERESTED.
WE SIMPLY NEED TO GIVE THEM THE
ENCOURAGEMENT AND THE TOOLS TO
GET THERE.
AS THE LEADER IN ENGINEERING AND
AS A CHAMPION OF GENDER EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY AND
EMPOWERING WOMEN IN ENGINEERING.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND CELEBRATING
INTRODUCE A GIRL TO ENGINEERING
DAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A C. R..
TWENTY ONE I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN
THE FIRST ROLL CALL FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT IF ACR
TWENTY ONE INTRODUCED SEEN A
GIRL TO ENGINEERING DAY.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR TAKING UP THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
AS WE ALL KNOW WOMEN AND GIRLS
ARE WOEFULLY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
THE FIELDS OF ENGINEERING
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
SO I RISE TODAY FOR THAT LITTLE
EIGHT YEAR OLD GIRL WHO JUST
ACED HER ELEVENS TIMES TABLES.
I RISE TODAY FOR THAT SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD GIRL HE WOKE UP EARLY
TO STUDY FOR HER CALCULUS TEST.
AND I RISE TODAY FOR THAT YOUNG
WOMAN WHO SHOWED UP AT WORK AND
FOUND HERSELF ONCE AGAIN TO BE
THE ONLY GIRL IN THE ROOM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR RAISING
THIS ISSUE WE AS A BODY I
SUPPORT YOU CONTINUED SUCCESS OF
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN THE FIELDS OF
TECHNOLOGY AND SCIENCE.
IS SO IMPORTANT TO THE CONTINUED
SUCCESS OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR
ECONOMY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS.
RESOLUTION AND AS AN ENGINEER
MYSELF ALSO I KNOW THAT YOUNG
GIRLS NEED TO BE EXPOSED EARLY
AND OFTEN BEFORE HIGH SCHOOL TO
A AND THE STEM FIELDS TO
ENGINEERING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO.
I WOULD URGE ALL THE MEMBERS
HERE IF YOU HAVE A ROBOTICS
WORKSHOP.
THAT YOU COULD SPONSOR OR AT
LEAST GO TO AND SUPPORT YOUNG
WOMEN OR A MAKER SPACE WHERE
THEY'RE FOCUSING ON ON YOUNG
GIRLS.
PLEASE DO THAT THAT'S HOW WE CAN
ENCOURAGE YOUNG YOUNG GIRLS TO
CONSIDER ENGINEERING FOR A
CAREER.
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR WOMEN IN
GENERAL TO HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO TO PARTAKE IN THE
STEM FIELDS TO KNOW THAT THEY
CAN DO IT.
BECAUSE THESE ARE VERY LUCRATIVE
CAREERS AND THERE IF THEY CAN BE
VERY EXCITING CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES TO AND FINALLY
IT'S REALLY OF BENEFIT TO
BUSINESSES TO HAVE MORE YOUNG OF
WOMEN --
EXPLORE ENGINEERING BECAUSE IT
WILL IT HAS SHOWN IT'S BEEN
SHOWN TO LEAD TO ADDITIONAL
CREATIVITY AND INNOVATION SO AS
WAS MENTIONED BEFORE IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT --
WE DIVERSIFY OUR ENGINEERS ANNA
FOR THE FUTURE OF A CALIFORNIA
SO I WANT TO THANK AGAIN THE
AUTHOR. FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITHIN
SPEAKER SAM MEMBER I RISE TO
SUPPORT ACR.
TWENTY ONE AND DOT AS AN
ENGINEER MYSELF I KNOW IT IS SO
VERY REWARDING EXCITING AND
CHALLENGING FEEL TO THE END --
IS REWARDING A PERSONALLY AS
WELL -- AT
AS THE TWO COUNTRIES COUNTRY
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR COMMUNITY --
EVEN SOLD WOMAN HOUSE COULD I
HAVE 13%.
BUT WHEN I JOIN IBM BACK IN THE
LATE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT ALL OF
TWENTY ENGINEERS IN MY GROUP
THERE WAS ONLY ONE FEMALE SO WAS
LIKE LESS THAN 5%.
AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE
INCREASE ENLARGE THE GOVERNOR
THE WALLET TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM NORTH HOLLYWOOD.
TO BRING THOSE VERY IMPACTFUL
WORRIED COULD.
ON THIS ISSUE AND AND BRING IN
THOSE RESOLUTION ON THE FLOOR I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I THANK YOUR SOMEONE NUMBER TWO
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER READ THIS
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR SUPPORTING IN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR CO AUTHORS
AND FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST ROLL ON ACR TWENTY ONE
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED --
PLEASE NOTE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRED --
PLEASE VOTE.
THIS ONE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
MAY SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS
UNEASY ARE.
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE FOR A VOTE ON AC
[inaudible]
HELLO.
OBJECTION IS THERE AN OBJECTION
TO A VOICE VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL HAVE A
VOICE VOTE ON ACR TWENTY ONE ALL
IN FAVOR SAY AYE [inaudible]
ALL OPPOSE.
THE RESOLUTION PASSES IT WILL BE
PASSED IN RETAINS.
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE'S A RESOLUTION ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE.
ONE ROLL CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON IS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY BY SOME THE MEMBER THREE
OF US AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
ENGINEERS WEEK.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS
A CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS TO ADD ON AS CO
AUTHORS TO THIS RESOLUTION ON
CONSENSUS.
MEMBER THIS VOTE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL APPLY THAT --
TO THE RESOLUTION THAT IS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR A SOMETHING
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
PRICE ONLY MEMBER THREE OF US
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO ENGINEERS
WEEK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ON THE
CALENDARS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WHERE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY?
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR
GERMANS TO MEMORY AND GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION HER
COLLEAGUES.
THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT LEFT IN.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ANY GERMAN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR THESE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MR GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE GINGER THE
MEMORY OF AMANDA GARCIA.
WHOSE LIFE WAS CUT SHORT AFTER A
COURAGEOUS BATTLE WITH CANCER.
AMANDA LIVED FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS ON THIS EARTH TO THE
FULLEST WITH BOUNDLESS
POSITIVITY.
SHE WAS IMPRESSIVE STUDENT
ATHLETE.
RANKING AMONG THE TOP TEN
ATHLETES OF ALL TIME IN THE
EIGHT HUNDRED METERS AT SAC
STATE.
SHE RECEIVED A BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE IN NUTRITION AND SHE PUT
TO USE WORKING FOR NUTRITIONAL
SCIENCE COMPANY IN CHICAGO.
WHERE SHE WAS QUICKLY PROMOTED?
AMANDA DEMONSTRATE TREMENDOUS
STRENGTH AND PERSEVERANCE TO
ENTER THE OVERWHELMING OBSTACLE
SHE WAS DEL.
SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED FONDLY BY
THOSE WHOSE LIVES SHE TOUCHED.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER PARENTS
ORDER.
AND LEE A BORDO.
SISTER BREANNA.
HER BOYFRIEND DANIEL.
AS WELL AS HER LOVING EXTENDED
FAMILY IN A WIDE CIRCLE OF
FRIENDS.
TODAY AMANDA'S FAMILY JOINS US
IN THE GALLERY.
ON BEHALF OF THE TWENTY FIRST
DECEMBER DISTRICT AND ALL THOSE
WHO KNEW AMANDA.
I ASKED WE JENNIFER MEMBER TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF MICHAEL JOSEPH Và
GERA.
A DEAR FRIEND A CONSTITUENT A
COMMUNITY LEADER.
WHEN THE CITY OF VACAVILLE?
MIKE RECENTLY PASSED AWAY AT THE
TENDER AGE OF SIXTY THREE AFTER
YOUR LONG FIGHT WITH AN ADVANCED
MELANOMA.
HE LEAVES BEHIND. TO BE TO MOURN
AND REMEMBER HIS DEVOTED WIFE OF
THIRTY SIX YEARS DEBBIE SEGERA.
HIS DAUGHTERS LAWRENCE GARRETT
VASQUEZ AND ALYSSA SECURA --
SAID HE WAS THE BEST DAD TWO
GIRLS COULD ASK.
FOR HIS LOVING MOTHER.
JOANNE SECURE A ROOM EL HIS
BROTHER MANUAL SECURA.
AND MANY OTHER AUNTS UNCLES
NIECES NEPHEWS WHO LOVED HIM
DEARLY.
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY HE BECAME
EXXON'S YOUNG SIMPLY.
WORKING WITH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
AND ULTIMATELY HE BECAME THE ONE
AND ONLY HONORARY MEMBER OF THE
BACK OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION.
MIKE WAS A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR.
WHO HANDY WORK TOUCH SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PRIVATE
RESIDENCES ALIKE?
THERE WAS NOTHING HE COULDN'T
BUILD.
AS A CONSTANT PILLAR OF HIS
COMMUNITY MIKE VOLUNTEERED MUCH
OF HIS FREE TIME. TO SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS.
MOST RECENTLY HE WAS PART OF THE
LOGISTICS COMMITTEE FOR
MERRIMENT ON MAIN.
THE VICE COMMODORE OF THE
TAXABLE CLUB.
AND THE BACK OF WILL MUSEUM
VOLUNTEER.
MIKE WAS A TRUE OUTDOORSMAN.
WHO ENJOYS DON'T SNOWMOBILING
FISHING HUNTING OFF ROADING?
AND A COLD BEER ON FRIDAY NIGHT.
HE LOVED TO TRAVEL ENJOYING THE
ITALIAN COUNTRYSIDE AS MUCH AS
THE CALIFORNIA COASTLINE AND THE
DEEP OFTEN CHOPPY WATERS OF
ALASKA.
THE BEACHES OF HAWAII VENTURE
BECAME A SECOND HOME TO HIM WE
FOUND AS MUCH TO IN EXPLORING
Là CAVES HE DID.
HIS LOCAL THE LOCAL BECAUSE
HUSING CUISINE.
MIKE SECURE WILL BE MISSED BY
HIS FAMILY AND HIS COMMITTEE
LIKE MAY REST IN PEACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
MR KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS TODAY.
TODAY I RISE FOR MEMBER THE LIFE
OF GAIL GA STEEL OF ROOSEVELT.
GAIL WAS BORN ON JULY FIFTEENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX IN VIVIAN
SOUTH DAKOTA AND WAS THE OLDEST
OF THREE CHILDREN BORN TO
MAYNARD AND MERRY STOLEN.
BEGINNING IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
GALE WAS A FLIGHT NURSE FOR THE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE WHERE SHE
ATTAINED THE RANK OF CAPTAIN.
SHE MET THE LOVE OF HER LIFE
WITH TENET COLONEL JACK OF STEEL
WHEN SHE WAS STATIONED AT FORBES
GALEN JACK WENT ON TO HAVE THREE
CHILDREN GINNY'S IN MICHELLE AND
JOHN.
LATER IN HER LIFE SHE WENT TO
SCHOOL WHERE SHE EARNED A
BACHELOR OF SCIENCE IN NURSING
FROM INCARNATE WORLD WORD
UNIVERSITY.
SHE ALSO OBTAINED HER SCHOOL
NURSE CREDENTIAL FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO.
AND SHE EARNED HER MASTER OF
SCIENCE IN SCHOOL COUNSELING
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF LAVERNE
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE GAIL
RECEIVE GREAT SATISFACTION FROM
HER WORK AS A SCHOOL NURSE
WORKING FOR THE SACRAMENTO CITY
SAN JUAN UNIFIED AN ELDORADO
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT'S.
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
SHE HAD A LOT OF TRAVEL AND
ADVENTURE AND ENJOYED ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS RUNNING SKIING TENNIS
AND HIKING.
WITH THE ARRIVAL OF HER
GRANDSON'S CALL AN ANDREW
MATTHEW YOU COULD ALWAYS COUNT
ON GAIL TO BE CHEERING THE
LOUDEST AS SHE NEVER MISSED.
A SPORTING MATCH YET BASKETBALL
SOCCER LACROSSE OR VOLLEYBALL.
SHE WAS A LOVING MOTHER.
GRANDMOTHER WIFE AND FRIEND.
GAIL PASSED AWAY SURROUNDED BY
HER FAMILY AND HER LOVING
HUSBAND.
ON JANUARY THIRTEENTH. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TODAY WE HONOR
AN AMAZING WOMAN.
WHOSE PASSION DEDICATION AND
KIND HEARTED ATTITUDE.
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED.
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I REQUEST
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF GAIL
STEEL.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESTINY PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
OUR QUESTION JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
TOMORROW IS THE DEADLINE TO
INTRODUCE BILLS I'M ORDERING THE
DEATHS TO BE HELD OPEN UNTIL
FIVE PM TODAY AND TOMORROW.
OR UNTIL THE LAST BILL IS
RECEIVED FROM LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL TO PROCESS BILL
INTRODUCTIONS.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
THERE IS NO FLOOR SESSION OR
CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAINS ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WHILE THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH AT ONE PM.
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED